بالانتقال الان الى تطورات الاوضاع في
السودان قال قائد الجيش السوداني ورئيس
مجلس السياده عبد الفتاح البرهان ان
القوات المسلحه لم تستخدم ما وصفها بالقوه
المميته وانها ستضطر الى ذلك اذا لم ينصع
العدو لصوت العقل حسب قوله واضاف البرهان
خلال تفقده قوه الجيش في مواقع لم يكشف
عنها ان الموافقه على تمديد الهدنه كانت
لتسهيل انسياب الخدمات للمواطنين واكد
البرهان ان القوات المسلحه السودانيه تقود
المعركه نيابه عن شعبها مشيرا الى ان جميع
المناطق والفرق لا تزال محتفظه بكامل
قوتها بعد ان بسطت سيطرتها على الجميع
انحاء البلاد
هذا وقد ساد الهدوء مناطق العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم وسد مراسل الجزيره
بسماع اطلاق نار متقطع جنوبي الخرطوم وفي
الخرطوم بحري للمتابعه معنا من جنوبي
الخرطوم مراسل للجزيره الطاهر المرضي
الطاهر اذا تطورات ميدانيه في ظل استمرار
الهدنه لكن الابرز هو كلام قائد الجيش
رئيس مجلس السياده عبد الفتاح البرهان
امام
منتسبي الجيش بعد ظهر اليوم
نعم هذا هو الحدث الابرز خاصه وان هذه
الجوله تاتي على درجه عاليه من الاهميه
بالنسبه لقوات
الشعب المسلحه وان رئيس مجلس السياده
القائد العام للجيش السوداني بهذه الجوله
وسط جنوده يريد ان يرسل عدد من الرسائل
اولى هذه الرسائل هي انه يريد يقول للجيش
السوداني انه موجود وسط جنوده وان القوات
المسلحه متماسكه وتسيطر على جميع انحاء
السودان وانها تستطيع ان تحسم هذه ما
وصفهم بالمتمردين في اي لحظه اذا ما
استخدم القوه المميته وايضا قال لي الجنود
يجب ان لا تلتفتوا الى ما يقال بان هذه
الحرب هي حرب ضد الذي يشنها او التي
يقولها وتقول القوات الدعم السريع انها ضد
النظام السابق يقول لهم الحرب هي حرب
للكرامه وحرب من اجل الشعب السوداني
الرساله الثانيه يريد ايضا ان يبعد بهذه
الرساله الى المجتمع الدولي ان الجيش
السوداني يحترم حقوق الانسان والقانون
الدولي لحقوق الانسان ولذلك لم يستخدم حتى
الان القوه المميته في هذا الاطار ولكنه
قال اذا اضطر الى ذلك سيستخدم هذه القوه
المميته وهذه رساله واضحه للمجتمع الدولي
والاقليمي بالضغط على قوات الدعم السريه
للاستجابه او تقدير العمل على تحقيق
الحوار وتحقيق
السلام وفق ما يراه مناسبا للظروف الحاليه
ودمج هذه القوات كما كان يطالب دائما في
الجيش السوداني وانهاء هذه الازدواجيه في
وجود جيشين في السودان الرساله الاخرى
ايضا للشعب السوداني يقول الرئيس مجلس
السياده انه يشعر بالذي
بالسودانيين من نزوح واعتداءات
وماذاقوه من ويلات الحرب ولذلك يقول انه
وافق على هذه الهدنه من اجل الشعب
السوداني حتى يستطيع ان يحقق الاغراض التي
وقعت من اجل هذه الهدنه وهي المتعلقه
بالظروف الانسانيه والاوضاع الانسانيه
وفتح المسارات وهي اعاده تاهيل المستشفيات
في هذا الاطار وانه يعني يعني يرسل هذه
الرسائل بشكل واضح وهي تعتبر الحدث الابرز
من خلال هذه الجوله بعد توقيع الهدنه هذه
الحديث ياتي في اطار تماسك هدنه الى درجه
ما في يومها الاول التي وقعت هدنه الخمسه
ايام التي يعني نشا فيها هدوءا كبيرا
وتقول الجهات التي تيسر هذه المفاوضات
بانها تسعى في نهايه هذه الهدنه الى توقيع
اتفاق وقف اطلاق النار بعيد الامد او
لربما يكون لمده شهر اذا ما نجحت
المفاوضات في هذا الاطار من اجل العمل
الانساني ومساعده السودانيين الذين تاثروا
بهذه الحرب لجوءا ونزوحا شكرا لك الطاهر
المرضي مراسله الجزيره من الجنوبيه
الخرطوم